Computer, wie spät ist es?
Sofort eine Verbindung zum Fritz-Server aufbauen. Verbindung hergestellt. Soll das aktuelle Programm angewählt werden?
Bitte geben Sie die Zukunftscode ein. Kabelsalat ist gesund. Zugriffgewähr zum aktuellen Programm. Voller Durchblick bei Chaosradio.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 30 und das Thema in dieser Episode soll sein Freie Radios und ZIPFM, ein Nachrichtenmagazin im freien Radio-Verbund. Zu Gast ist Vera von ZIPFM und am Mikrofon begrüßt euch, wie gehabt, Tim Pritlove. Willkommen wieder bei Chaosradio Express. Ist einiges passiert. Letzte Woche war ich bei den Datenspuren. Ihr werdet es mitbekommen haben. Dort habe ich ja das Gespräch geführt mit Alva. Und das war mal wieder etwas längerer Podcast. Da wollen wir uns jetzt mal ein bisschen beschränken heute. Kurzer Hinweis noch in eigener Sache. Die Aufzeichnungen der Datenspuren werden auch bald veröffentlicht werden und sie werden auch bei Chaosradio ccc.de veröffentlicht werden. Der Plan ist künftig Aufzeichnungen von den CCC-Veranstaltungen als Podcast generell bereitzustellen. Mit den Datenspuren fangen wir an. Kongress wird jetzt bald folgen. Und ja, Datenspuren 2005 vom letzten Jahr ist bereits online. Könnt ihr schon mal schauen. Und 2006 wird bald folgen. Ja, und jetzt wird es langsam mal Zeit, hier auch mal den Gast zu begrüßen. Hallo. Du warst ja auch auf den Datenspuren.
Jupp.
Und hast auch einen Bericht gemacht von den Datenspuren, den wir auch schon veröffentlicht haben bei Chaos TV. Wie hat es dir da gefallen?
Ich fand es super auf den Datenspuren. Ich würde auch jedes Jahr wieder hinfahren und würde allen empfehlen, auch zu kommen. Das ist echt super.
Du warst ja ganz fleißig, hast irgendwie viele Interviews geführt mit Gästen, mit Leuten, die da waren, auch mit Referenten und Organisatoren. Was war so dein Eindruck von der Veranstaltung nach hinein?
Ich würde sagen, es waren ja so 100 bis 150 Leute, dass es eine große Familie, aber schon ziemlich familiär ist, diese Datenspuren. Es treffen sich interne, aber auch so ein paar Leute, die einfach mal so reinkommen, weil es Datenspuren, Privatsphäre war gestern, das Thema schon ganz spannend klingt. Aber es waren schon viele, die sich untereinander kennen, aber auf jeden Fall auch sich sehr viel Spannendes zu erzählen haben.
Ja, ich finde den Zustand ganz interessant, weil es mit Abstand die Veranstaltung im CCC ist, die am wenigsten auf Technik fokussiert ist. Also eigentlich ist keine Veranstaltung vollständig auf Technik fokussiert, aber Technik spielt natürlich auch immer eine große Rolle und das bei den Datenspuren natürlich nur so die zweite Abteilung. Es geht sehr viel mehr um Bürgerrechte. Und man hat gemerkt, dass die Themenlage da auch ziemlich heiß ist derzeit.
Aber trotzdem waren schon fast alle Leute mit Laptop da und wie Jens es so ausdrückte, es waren nur wenige Leute da, die auch nicht mit ihren Freunden wie mit Computern und die mit ihren Computern wie Freunden reden, aber ein paar wenige waren da. So auch einfach wie Sozialwissenschaften studiert haben oder so.
Ja, den Eindruck hatte ich allerdings auch, dass es ganz gut gemischt war. Und Laptop gibt es ja mittlerweile nicht nur die Nerds, die damit rumlaufen. Ja, du machst Radio, das hatte ich jetzt schon erwähnt. Und zwar machst du Radio bei ZIPFM. Mir wurde gerade noch mal nachdrücklich nahegelegt, es nicht ZIPFM auszusprechen, was natürlich so ein bisschen da liegt. Aber die Verbindung zu der Abkürzung, zu der Datei-Endung gibt es ja schon, oder?
Ja, die ist riesig. Das, glaube ich, liegt einfach daran, dass der Nerd-Anteil unter den Leuten, die ZIPFM machen, nicht allzu gering ist und damit einfach diese Abkürzung reingekommen ist. Aber damit es nicht halt so technisch klingt, ist es halt schon ZIPFM. Oder vielleicht nennen wir es eines Tages um, in Ra.FM, aber da wüsste ich dann nicht mehr, wie man die Abkürzung aussprechen sollte, oder? BZ2 oder so.
Okay, also es geht sozusagen um die kompakte Zusammenfassung von Inhalten.
Genau.
Ist das eine gute Beschreibung?
Das ist eine gute Beschreibung, ja.
Welche Inhalte macht denn ZIPFM? Was wird denn da eingepackt? Kannst du uns vielleicht mal kurz vorstellen, was ZIPFM genau ist?
Ja, ZIPFM hat einfach eine Geschichte. Es liegt daran, dass es zwar freie Radios schon länger gibt, aber immer weniger Leute bei den freien Radios auch Infobeträge produzieren. Einfach Nachrichten, Polit und Infobeträge. Aber eigentlich haben die freien Radios den Anspruch, ziemlich viel Polit-Inhalt einfach rüberzubringen. Dann haben wir beschlossen, alle freien Radios, die Lust haben, tun sich mal zusammen und produzieren selber einen Info jeden Tag, gemeinsam, und alle Leute, die Bock haben und alle freien Radios können es dann ausstrahlen.
Um es noch mal zusammenzufassen, ZIPFM ist ein Sendeformat, was auf freien Radios ausgestrahlt wird. Dazu sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen, was freie Radios sind. Freie Radios sind halt Radios, die jetzt nicht Privatsendern gehören, die nicht in irgendeiner Form in ARD-Landschaften öffentlich-rechtliche Strukturen eingebaut sind.
Ja, und vor allem halt auch keine Werbung bringen, nicht politisch finanziert werden oder irgendwas, sondern einfach alle Leute, die Lust haben, interessiert sind und keine Lust auf Commerz haben und noch Lust haben dazu entweder andere Musik oder einfach anderen Inhalt, als was in den Mainstream-Medien so kommt, rüberzubringen, die können zu den freien Radios gehen. Es gibt nicht überall in Deutschland freie Radios, aber in fast allen großen Städten, ein paar Bundesländer haben das zum Beispiel gar nicht. Selbst Berlin, wo ich hier gerade sitze, zum Beispiel hat kein freies Radio.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ein Skandal. Es gibt ja schon seit längeren Zeit hier eine Initiative, die versucht, so ein freies Radio an den Start zu kriegen. Jetzt fällt mir gerade nicht ein. radiokampagne.de. Genau, radiokampagne.de. Und die sind da schon lange am Streiten.
Die sind auch, so seit zwei Jahren sind sie langsam wirklich wieder aktiv, sich drum zu kümmern, dass es was wird. Und das Problem in Berlin ist, dass sie zusammengefasst sind, die Landesmedienanstalt mit Brandenburg und Berlin. Und Berlin hat inzwischen zugesagt, dass es ein freies Radio geben darf. Aber das Land Brandenburg muss noch überredet werden.
Ah, es darf eins geben. Also sie sagen nicht, dass es eins geben wird, aber...
Sie sagen erst mal, es darf eins geben. Aber das ist erst mal ein erster Schritt. Also bisher war es einfach verboten. Und dann, wenn es gesagt wird, es darf eins geben, dann wird auch oder muss auch einfach Geld von der Landesmedienanstalt Berlin-Brandenburg einfach fließen, damit freies Radio entstehen kann.
Und du bist ja, du bist nicht aus Berlin.
Ich wohne zurzeit in Freiburg.
Und dort gibt es auch ein freies Radio.
Ja, wir sind das Radio Dreieckland. Das ist das älteste freie Radio in Deutschland überhaupt. Entstand in den 70ern einfach tatsächlich. Dort ging es noch darum, überhaupt irgendwie Infos in die Medien zu bringen, die nicht Mainstream sind. Da war es noch schlimmer als es jetzt schon ist. Inzwischen ist ja schon so, dass Deutschland, Funk etc. auch mal andere Nachrichten oder Infos verbreiten. Damals war es einfach alles normiert. Was meinst du mit anderen Infos? Einfach Leute, die Lust haben aus ihrem politischen Zusammenhängen zum Beispiel zu berichten. Also linke Themen kamen einfach damals gar nicht vor. Da ist es entstanden aus dem Castor-Widerstand einfach. Damals noch. Da war es auch alles noch einfacher, weil die Grenzen so schön verliefen.
Also Castor-Widerstand, die Widerstandsbewegung gegen die Pläne in Lüchow-Dannenberg.
Nee, da ging es eher direkt um AKW, AKW Fessenheim. In der Nähe von Freiburg? In der Nähe von Freiburg. Und da sind vor allem auch viele Bauern und so waren einfach dagegen. Und Radio Fessenheim hieß das auch noch früher, ist dann entstanden aus dieser ganzen Bewegung überhaupt und haben dort Piratenradio gemacht, was auch noch einfacher war als jetzt, weil die ganze Technik noch nicht da war, von Fürpeilwägen etc. und Freiburg liegt im Dreieckland, das heißt, man konnte halt mal schnell über die Grenze springen nach Frankreich, dann gab es dann einfach Probleme mit der Verfolgung und dann wurde halt mal aus Frankreich gesendet.
Dreieckland heißt das wegen Schweiz, Frankreich, Deutschland. Genau.
Radio Dreieckland wird mit E, Y geschrieben.
Ist das dann so der besondere Spin jetzt oder ist das so eine übliche Bezeichnung für die Radio?
Das ist einfach alemannisch. Also ich kann leider überhaupt nicht alemannisch sprechen, aber die Leute, die dort unten angefangen haben, Radios zu machen, die haben halt nicht hochdeutsch gesprochen, sondern alemannisch.
Bist du dann wenigstens bei der Fastnacht mit dabei?
Nein. Ich kann zugegebenermaßen nicht leiden.
Okay, dein Beitrag liegt konkret jetzt in der Radioprogrammgestaltung, wir haben es schon erwähnt, ZIPFM. Und ZIPFM ist jetzt quasi ein Nachrichtenmix, eine halbe Stunde, richtig?
Ja, viermal die Woche.
Viermal die Woche.
Nein, es ist Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag und Freitag.
Okay, Dienstag, Mittwoch, also Montag muss man einfach ausschlafen.
Montag muss man einfach wochenlanger ausschlafen. Ich glaube, das wirkliche Problem ist, warum Montag im Moment nicht gibt, weil es zu wenig Leute gibt, die überhaupt Beiträge machen. Und am Wochenende wird noch weniger Radio produziert als unter der Woche, und dann ist Montag einfach noch lau mit Infos.
Wie ich es richtig verstanden habe, ZIPFM ist ja jetzt nicht die Arbeit einer einzelnen Redaktion, sondern das Zepter wird dann von Tag zu Tag immer weiter gereicht.
Also eine kleine Gruppe würde das gar nicht schaffen, weil es einfach wirklich jeden Tag produziert wird, also viermal die Woche. Und das ist wahnsinnig viel Arbeit. Also man braucht da schon drei bis fünf Stunden. Auch die Leute, die schon fünf Jahre Radio machen, brauchen einfach so lang. Und da gibt es jeweils eine Gruppe pro Stadt meistens, die sich an einem Tag um das ZIPFM kümmert. Wir zum Beispiel in Freiburg kümmern uns um den Dienstag.
Immer genau an dem Tag.
Immer Dienstag. Wir machen immer Dienstag.
Und wer sind dann die anderen drei, die sich kümmern?
Mittwoch wird in Marburg produziert, Radio Unerhört Marburg. Donnerstag wird von verschiedenen produziert. Meistens von Radio Z, aus Nürnberg. Und einmal, glaube ich, noch Ulm, aber das wechselt manchmal. Freitag ist Berlin. In Berlin gibt es zwar kein freies Radio, aber es gibt Leute, die sich darum kümmern, dass hier trotzdem ZIPFM produziert wird und es dann ins Netz gestellt wird, damit alle das wieder aus dem Netz sich runterladen können. Und aus Tübingen.
Sind die Wiener nicht auch von Zeit zu Zeit mal beschäftigt?
Ja, das Stichspringen, das rotiert öfter mal, Donnerstag und Freitag, wird hin und wieder gemischt. Mal hat auch Hannover noch Zeit, um mal schnell eine ZIPFM zu machen und Wien auch.
Okay, also die regelmäßigen Bastionen sozusagen, die ist in Freiburg und in Marburg angesiedelt.
Und näher in Nürnberg auf jeden Fall noch ganz wichtig.
Und ja, kannst du mal was zum Format selber sagen? Also, ihr habt eine halbe Stunde, woraus setzt die sich in der Regel zusammen?
Die setzt sich aus der Regel erst mal natürlich aus einem Jingle zusammen, wie hier auch, dann aus eigentlich vier Beiträgen. Manchmal sind es auch drei oder fünf. Die sind jeweils eigentlich sechseinhalb Minuten. Das ist unser Wunschtraum, also der Wunschtraum der Moderatorin, weil wir ja auch noch das Ganze moderieren müssen. Das sieht dann nämlich so aus, dass wir in unserem, auf unserer Austauschseite der Radios schauen, ob es gerade kurze Beiträge gibt, das heißt irgendwas zwischen fünf und acht minütigen Beiträgen, die technisch okay sind, inhaltlich gut sind. Wir bearbeiten die dann halt noch häufig nach oder nehmen sie so, müssen allerdings noch eine Moderation, also moderieren die dann einfach noch wie so ein Magazin. Also es kommt nicht Anfang, dann Jingle, dann Zwischenmusik, dann moderieren wir, dann kommt Beitrag, dann wieder unsere Moderation und so weiter. Genau, wie Deutschlandfunk. Also ganz schlimme, das ist eigentlich, ich finde, ich höre Deutschlandfunk ja gerne, aber es gibt viele der freien Radios, aus der freien Radioszene, die damit gar nicht so glücklich sind, weil freies Radio ja nicht Deutschlandfunk heißt und kein total tolles Format, sondern heißt Radio von unten. Aber ZIPFM ist halt schon ein Programmradio, also schon Format.
Ich meine, es macht die Sache natürlich auch für den den Hörer einfacher, wenn man sich erst mal eine gewisse Struktur gewöhnt hat. So fließt es irgendwie besser in einen rein. Ja, ganz vielleicht mal kurz, was mir interessiert ist, wie so der Produktionsaufwand ist, weil viele Leute, die jetzt auch Chaosradio hören, hören sicherlich auch noch andere Podcasts und ist ja auch mal so ein bisschen die Frage, wie organisiere ich so etwas, ein eigenes Programm zu machen. Das ist ja das eine, aber Content aus anderen Quellen zusammenzubauen, ist ja noch mal eine ganz andere Herausforderung. Ich kenne eigentlich nur einen Podcast, der auch so ein bisschen versucht, magazinmäßig zu sein, aus Amerika, wo sie halt auch mehrere Beiträge haben, dann auch mal so mit Moderation am Anfang, dann irgendwie darauf verweisen, also das mehr so kapitelartig ausstreuen, also wirklich wie ein Magazin sind. Bei euch ist es ja wirklich eine zusammenhängende Nachrichtensendung, und die Moderation versucht dann so ein bisschen den Klebstoff zwischen den Beiträgen irgendwie herbeizuleiten. Also wie gehst du da ran? Wie kriegst du die Beiträge und vor allem woher?
Das woher ist, das ist alles eine relativ schwierige Frage. Also ich gehe da meistens, ich habe Dienstag, ich habe einfach Glück. Das heißt, ich kann mich Montag, Nachmittag oder wenn ich Zeit habe, schon mal dransetzen ans Internet, erst mal gucken, was haben alle anderen freien Radios so in den letzten Stunden produziert.
Wo siehst du das?
Wir haben ein Radioportal www.freieradios.net. Dort können alle freien Radios, alle produzierenden Leute, die bei uns irgendwie halt Radio machen, ihre Beiträge hochstellen. Und dort kommen halt auch eigentlich übers Wochenende schon relativ viele Beiträge rein. Die schaue ich mir dann an und schaue, ob überhaupt welche da sind und welche, die mir zusagen.
Das heißt, du hast da so einen eigenen Login und siehst sozusagen eingestellte Sachen. Das ist jetzt nicht öffentlich, die liegen da nicht einfach so rum.
Doch, die liegen rum. Die kann eigentlich auch jeder hören. Sie sind nicht kommerziell weiter zu verwenden. Sie liegen bald unter der Queer-Teuf-Commons-Lizenz. Aber es ist halt im Prinzip tatsächlich, als das gegründet wurde, 1998 wurde das Regal genannt. Also die Leute stellen ihre Beiträge da rein, wie in so einem Regal. Und alle anderen freien Radios können sie sich dort abholen und weiterverwenden. Das machen wir halt bei ZIPFM auch. Schauen, was da gerade so im Netz rumliegt, ob sie verwendbar sind. Und dann fängt eigentlich die Arbeit erst an, weil da sind einfach Beiträge drin, von denen ich überhaupt keine Ahnung habe, wo ich ein ganz neues, spannendes Thema, ich musste einmal anfangen, erst mal über Uruguay nachzulesen, weil ich persönlich nicht weiß, wie die politische Situation da ist. Die Beiträge, die dort drin sind, sind halt in einem Kontext dort im Radio entstanden. Das heißt, die Leute, die Moderatorinnen, die wissen natürlich, was sie vorher erzählen müssen oder so. Und ich muss aber anfangen, erst mal alles zu lesen. Das kann echt dauern. Hochliebe Wikipedia, würde ich in dem Fall sagen.
Ja, wichtiges Werkzeug.
Auf jeden Fall auch für uns wichtiges Werkzeug. Aber oft ist es dann auch hin und wieder in den seltensten Fällen, ist es dann so, dass ich echt vier tolle Radiobeiträge finde und auch anfange, Moderation zu schreiben und mich selber darüber zu informieren. Wenn ich Pech habe, was hin und wieder vorkommt, habe ich eins, zwei, drei Beiträge und muss mir dann noch zwei oder drei oder einen Beitrag aus dem Ärmel zaubern.
Gibt es denn eine Diskussion jetzt unter den Gruppen über die Inhalte, also über die Sendung hinaus? Gibt es irgendwie eine Maßgabe, was man zu nehmen hat oder was man nicht zu nehmen hat? Ist da so eine Kritik, so ein Lagerfeuer?
Wir haben ja auch eine Lagerfeuer, auf jeden Fall eine Lagerfeuer-Kritik. Wir treffen uns bis zu vier Mal im Jahr wirklich als Gruppe. Ansonsten haben wir eine Mailing-Liste.
Dann an wechselnden Orten nehme ich mal an.
An wechselnden Orten.
Jede Stadt einmal dran und so.
Ja, wir machen das meistens so, dass im Winter wir irgendwas mit dem Urlaub verbinden. Also wir waren zweimal im Schwarzwald zum Beispiel. Dann bringen ihre Leute ihre Schirr mit und gehen halt nebenbei noch. Gibt es keine Lagerfeuer-Radio-Kritik, sondern Abfahrts- und Glühwein-Radio-Kritik. Letztens waren wir auch in Tübingen, dann war auch einfach mal ein Radiotrans zum Beispiel. Oder wir haben auch ein, es gibt einmal im Jahr, wo wir uns auf jeden Fall auch treffen, in Makelfinger am Boden sehen, in einem Radiocamp. Und dann gibt es immer ein Treffen halt nur von uns und Leute, die Interesse haben.
Wie groß ist so diese Community, die man sich dahinter vorstellen muss?
Verdammt klein. Also wenn es hoch kommt, sind wir zehn bei den Treffen. Also zwölf Leute, würde ich sagen, sind wirklich aktiv dabei. Und dann gibt es halt schon noch Leute, die so mitmachen.
Ja, weil das ist ja schon eine ganz gute Basis, würde ich sagen.
Es ist eine gute Basis, aber...
Vielleicht muss man erst mal zusammenkriegen, die gemeinsam daran arbeiten, was regelmäßig rauszuhauen.
Ja, aber wenn zum Beispiel in einem freien Radio, wie in Freiburg, 200 Leute produzieren eigentlich irgendwie, also die meisten machen Musik, aber Radio produzieren trotzdem, dann sind aus dem bundesweiten oder deutschsprachigen Raum, wir haben ja auch noch Schweiz und Österreich dabei, zwölf Leute, nicht wirklich viele.
Ja gut, aber jetzt ist natürlich so eine Nachrichtensendung auch eine ziemliche Herausforderung. Da muss man natürlich ganz anders drüber nachdenken. Bei Musik, naja Gott, da hat man vielleicht mal ein schlechtes Ding erwischt, so. Aber bei Nachrichten, denke ich mal, legt man ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht einen höheren Maßstab an sich selbst.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist das Problem. Also wir haben, wir zwölf quasi, wir acht bis zwölf Leute, haben natürlich schon einen hohen Maßstab. Also wir haben für uns selber vor allem, glaube ich, einen ziemlich hohen Maßstab und das schreckt aber auch Leute ab. Also wir kriegen relativ oft gesagt, super, ZIPFM ist super, ZIPFM muss es weitergeben. Wir haben öfter mal so Horolsszenarien, wir haben keine Lust mehr, wir hören jetzt auf. Aber dafür sind wir immerhin vier Jahre, senden wir vierte Mal die Woche, immer noch. Es wurde bestimmt schon dreimal gesagt, wir hören auf. Aber dann kommt immer wieder von außen, hey macht weiter, wir brauchen das, das ist nett. Aber wir werden schon so als Creme de la Creme der freien Radios angesehen, was Blödsinn ist. Also wir haben auch so angefangen, ich mache jetzt drei oder vier Jahre, im Moment, wir haben 2006 oder ich mache fünf Jahre Radio. Danke, mir war das zuviel, man war es auch nicht so klar. Und angefangen habe ich auch einfach irgendwie schon mit einem politischen Sendung und dann habe ich angefangen, ein Morgenradio zu machen und bin dann halt irgendwie zu ZIPFM gekommen und habe da erst angefangen wirklich immer besser, also für mich besser quasi zu werden, aber das ist der eigene Anspruch und von außen wird das halt schon Wahnsinn. Wie kriegst du das hin, viermal die Woche irgendwie Beiträge zu machen?
Du bist ja auch noch ziemlich jung. Wann hast du angefangen, dich so für das Radio-Thema zu interessieren?
Mit 17 habe ich angefangen, wie ich dazu gekommen bin. Ja, ich gebe es mal zu durch die Antifa. Einfach, wir haben uns gedacht, wir müssen jetzt mal anderes Propaganda machen und haben dann Antifa Radio gemacht.
Gegen Öffentlichkeit schaffen.
Einfach wirklich traditionell, wozu linke Radios, wo Freie Radios eigentlich da waren, gegen Öffentlichkeit schaffen. Genau, und dann habe ich gefallen, dran gefunden, bin da hängen geblieben und mache es halt immer noch.
Das heißt, die Antifa Szene hatte ich dann verloren, aber du bist sozusagen der Radioszene seitdem erhalten geblieben. Was glaube ich viele Leute, was bei mir selber immer wieder so ein Ahlfakt ist, deswegen sollte man es vielleicht auch noch mal erwähnen, wenn wir von freien Radios reden, reden wir ja tatsächlich von Orten, wo was produziert wird. Das heißt, es gibt da eine Studiosituation in der Regel. Kannst vielleicht gleich noch mal was zu sagen. Ich war jetzt gerade vor kurzem in Wien, da gibt es das Radio Orange. Die haben halt so Räume und eine Studiosituation. Es gibt halt so das Minimum an Technik, aber vor allem gibt es halt eine UKW-Frequenz, die wir ja gerade schon gehört haben, nicht unbedingt in allen Ländern so ohne weiteres rausgegeben wird. Das ist ausgerechnet in Berlin. Das ist eigentlich eine Farce. Das ist unvorstellbar. Wirklich, statt die immer so mit diesem Nimbus-Wede doch so frei und alternativ zu sein.
Wobei, da würde ich gleich doch noch mal drin einhaken. Ich glaube, letztes Jahr hatten wir ein Treffen mit ZIP.FM-Leuten, aber auch noch anderen freien Radioleuten. Und dann haben zwei Berliner uns dann mal gezeigt, wie die Landschaft der Leute aussieht, hier, die freies Radio machen wollen. Ich habe es nicht verstanden. Das war eine Skizze von zehn Radios, wo skizziert war, wer wen jetzt nicht leiden kann und wer doch mit wem irgendwie ums Eck zusammenarbeitet. Es war sehr mühsand. Wenn Berlin und Brandenburg tatsächlich beschließen sollten, hier es darf ein freies Radio geben, dann werde ich mir das auf jeden Fall mal angucken.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gibt es hier auch sehr viel radioangagierte und natürlich auch eine gewisse Piraten-Sender-Kultur. Mal gucken, das liegt jetzt nicht in unserer Hand, da zu entscheiden, wann das stattfinden wird. Aber wie ist es denn in Freiburg? Habt ihr da auch Räume?
Ja, wir haben Räume. Ich komme eigentlich aus Erfurt. Dort gibt es natürlich noch nicht so lange freies Radio. Das ist in der Wendeteil entstanden, als es ein bisschen Freiburg-Raum gab. Da wurde sich dann halt mal ein Piraten-Sender erkämpft und das gibt es halt auch immer noch. Die haben zum Beispiel total neue Räume. Da ist alles groß, hell, die Technik super. In Freiburg hingegen ist es völlig das Gegenteil. Die haben im Prinzip immer noch die gleichen Räume, wie seitdem das Radio legal ist.
Haben sie auch noch die gleiche Technik?
Ich würde fast sagen, ja, ich bin da hingekommen und habe einen Schreikrampf bekommen innerlich. Wahnsinn.
Aber es gibt Computer.
Aber es gibt immer mehr Computer. Es wird immer besser. Die meisten, also ich produziere zum Beispiel einfach, ich habe meinen Computer überall dabei und kann überall produzieren. Andere produzieren immer noch mit Kassetten und M&Ds. Das kommt tatsächlich von Radio zu Radio an. Aber wir haben Räume in Freiburg, Studios mit normalen Mischpulten etc. Und einfach Räume zum Treffen und zum Reden, Zeitung lesen etc. Und zum Denken, was man jetzt als nächstes für einen Beitrag machen will. Allerdings gehöre ich auch zu den Leuten, was eigentlich eine schlechte Angewohnheit ist, gerade von den Info-Leuten, nämlich ich produziere zu Hause. Ist deshalb wegen schlechter Angewohnheit, weil einfach das fehlt, was in den Freien Radios eigentlich dazu gehört, nämlich beim Kaffeetrinken gemeinsam weiterzuspinnen und sowohl politisch weiter zu überlegen, als auch rein beitragsmäßig radio-technisch. Aber es ist einfach netter.
Und wenn du deine Interviews machst, jetzt wie bei dem Datenspurenbericht, was nimmst du da so für Technik?
Ich nehme ganz normal ein Telefon, was per Kabel mit einem Mischpult verbunden ist. Das wiederum mit einem Computer und... Ein Telefon.
Für die Interviews?
Ja.
Du hast deine Interviews mit einem Telefon aufgenommen?
Die Telefon-Interviews, wenn ich zu Hause sitze.
Das mache ich nicht, wenn du jetzt vor Ort bist.
Wenn ich vor Ort bin, habe ich inzwischen ein MP3-Player mit Vorverstärker, einem Mikro. Einen von Sony. Ach so, das ist ein MP3-Player. Ein ziemlich billigerer Teil. Aber wir haben dann echt mal angefangen.
Ich meine, das Ding, mit dem du aufnimmst.
Naja, der MP3-Player, mit dem nehme ich auf.
Von Sony?
Nee, der ist nicht von Sony. Der ist von, da muss ich jetzt mal gucken, aber eigentlich will ich ja keine Schleichwerbung machen. Der ist von Max Field und der wird gar nicht mehr produziert. Das ist nur so kurz, den gibt es nur noch auf eBay. Aber wir haben mal eben angefangen zu schauen, wir in den Freien Radios, MP3-Player sind einfach praktischer als MD oder Kassetten. Was für uns überhaupt tauglich ist, weil die meisten von den Freien Radios können sich keine 200-Euro-Teile leisten überhaupt. Und was ist billig genug? Was hat einen ordentlichen Mikrofoneingang? Was funktioniert? Und damit...
Okay. Also man nimmt im Prinzip alles, was gerade zu finanzieren ist und was irgendwie das gewünschte Ergebnis erzeugt. Sofern seid ihr ja eigentlich, eigentlich seid ihr ja dann genauso dran wie die Podcasterszene auch. Bloß, dass ihr halt auch UKW macht.
Genau. Und wir können, also wir haben, es gibt natürlich, das ist der Vorteil, wir werden ja nicht unbedingt in Baden-Württemberg, aber in anderen Bundesländern läuft ja schon, fließt ja schon Geld von der Landesmedienanstalt. Das ist zwangsmäßig irgendwie so. Und da gibt es dann auch mal, da kann ich mir auch einen ordentlichen MD-Rekorder oder ähnliches ausleihen. Und ich kann mit den Leuten halt wirklich in ein Studio gehen, das ist schon ein Vorteil.
Stimmt.
Klingt gut. Klingt besser vermutlich, als ihr in deinem Zimmer.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber ich mache ja auch Wohnzimmerradio, von daher muss man mit ein bisschen Heil rechnen. Aber ich glaube, der Heil hält sich hier relativ in Grenzen mit dem Mikrofon, den wir gerade verwenden.
Aber klar, ist Podcast nicht so groß der Unterschied, außer dass wir halt UKW haben und wir auch selber im Podcast zu hören sind.
Genau, aber man produziert halt auch das Format so ein bisschen anders. Also allein schon diese Ausrichtung mit, wir machen genau eine halbe Stunde und keine Sekunde mehr und weniger, ist natürlich ein ganz anderer Ansatz.
Funktioniert bei uns auch nicht.
Funktioniert nicht, aber Pi mal Daumen ist es immer eine halbe Stunde.
Bei ZIPFM auf jeden Fall, bei anderen Radios.
Ja, das meinte ich jetzt gerade mit ZIPFM. Bei uns auf jeden Fall, ja. Mir gelingt das zum Beispiel gar nicht, weil ich finde ja die Freiheit eigentlich auch ganz gut, nicht an so einen Sendeplan gezwungen zu sein, aber es hat halt immer so beides seine Vor- und Nachteile. Aber sind denn diese Radios auch im Internet zu empfangen?
Ja, wir sind im Podcast zu hören über www.freieradios.net auch zu lokalisieren. Aber im Prinzip sind wir schon noch UKW.
Ich meine, gibt es auch Streaming?
Es gibt keinen Streaming direkt vom ZIPFM. Wir haben halt, weil ZIPFM eben eigentlich schon in den freien Radios angegliedert ist, sind wir da immer zu hören per Stream, wo auch die freien Radios Stream haben.
Klar, das war jetzt auch eher mal eine Frage. Jetzt nehmen wir doch mal ein Beispiel Radio Dreieckland. Die senden über UKW, aber die senden auch einen Stream.
Die senden inzwischen auch einen Stream. Es wird immer mehr mit Stream.
Zusätzlich kann man bei Freie Radios net sich einzelne Programme raussuchen. Ich hab das mal gemacht, da gibt es so eine Auswahl. Man muss sich im Prinzip seinen Podcast-Feed selber zusammenklicken. Man wählt aus, was man haben will, alles, was kommt, oder nur dieses Programm, nur von dem Sender, oder eben nur ZIPFM zum Beispiel. Es gibt, glaube ich, explizit für ZIPFM noch mal einen eigenen Auswahlpunkt. Das ist dann aber auch der Ort, wo man es sozusagen abonniert. Also falls jetzt jemand Interesse hat, ZIPFM zu abonnieren, dann kann er das da machen. Und wie siehst du das Thema Podcasting im Bezug auf Freie Radios und alternativen Content?
Oh, das ist eine extrem schwierige Frage. Also ich finde Podcasts super. Wir haben eine riesige Diskussion darüber. Also seit einiger Zeit diskutieren wir daran. Im Prinzip, seitdem es Podcasts gibt, diskutieren wir, ob es für uns Sinn hat. Wir haben eh das Problem, dass es ja alles zu digitalem Radio, also UKW, ja quasi abgeschafft wird, bald. Und damit haben wir einfach das Problem, wie senden wir, weil wir nicht eingeplant werden. Also wir als... Nein, es wird einfach alles umgestellt aufs digitale Radio. Und da sind sie wirklich gerade dabei. Und wir kriegen keine, wir kriegen keine Frequenzen. Das heißt, was machen wir? Also entweder wir kämpfen oder wir werden privat, wir werden wieder Piratenradios.
Ist das denn schon eine beschlossene Sache, dass das UKW, Analog-UKW, abgeschaltet wird?
Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe jetzt nicht im Plan, bis wann, aber wir, ja, es gibt die, genau, auf jeden Fall die Pläne und... Und damit wissen wir uns einfach beschäftigen, weil wir eigentlich auf unser UKW nicht mehr ganz angewiesen sind, weil wir ja schon über Stream inzwischen auch senden, aber unser Hauptaugenmerk ja immer noch in der Küche liegt. Also das heißt, die Leute, die ihr Küchenradio auch machen, auch uns hören können und nicht nur die Leute, die in der Küche hören können, die auch vernetzt sind. Und damit haben wir, also müssen wir natürlich aufs Netz ausweichen. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir das Problem, wenn wir alle immer mehr streamen oder auf Podcast umsteigen, fällt es den Leuten, die halt UKW abschaffen wollen, immer leichter zu sagen, hey, ihr braucht überhaupt keine Frequenz, ihr sendet doch eh schon im Internet und das wollen wir nicht, wir wollen beides. Aber das ist eine schwierige Diskussion.
Na gut, ich denke, UKW hat einen großen Vorteil, weil man eigentlich relativ wenig Technik braucht, um daran teilzunehmen. Heutzutage ist es zwar leicht zu sagen, na ja, bei Podcast braucht man ja nur einen Computer und nur einen Internetanschluss, aber wir alle wissen, dass sowas auch schnell mal wegbrechen kann, wenn man die passende Finanzierung für das Gerät oder eben auch für den Service in irgendeiner Form wegfällt. Und dann ist das natürlich schon ein ganz anderes Ding. Aber ich denke, es passt zumindest ganz gut zusammen. Also man muss halt auch schauen, wo man da...
Passend ist auf jeden Fall.
Genau. Ja, jetzt während ich hier parallel auf meinem Computer versuche zu verhindern, dass meine Festplatte voll läuft und ich gerade nach der langweiligsten Musik suche, die ich hier einfach mal ungefragt weghauen kann, wollte ich nochmal zurück auf... Auf was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich zurück? Ich wollte nochmal auf die Situation von freien Radios allgemein, und zwar in Bezug auf die Möglichkeiten, die man dort hat. Ich denke, dass vielen Leuten gar nicht bewusst ist, dass es so etwas gibt. Und es aber durchaus Leute geben kann, die vielleicht jetzt auch Chaosradio Express hören, die Lust hätten, dort selber Programme zu machen. Was ist denn so normalerweise das Prozedere, um daran teilzunehmen? Wer entscheidet, was gesendet wird, wer wann, wo was macht, wie legen sich denn diese Programme überhaupt fest?
Ich kann jetzt direkt, also wie es allgemein ist, kann ich schon erzählen, direkt auch noch von zwei Radios erzählen, weil ich halt Freiburg und Erfurt erlebt habe. Eigentlich ist es immer so, dass es irgendwie ein geartetes Plenum gibt, also ein Treffen, wo alle Mitglieder oder alle Leute kommen können, die Lust haben, Interesse haben, etc. Die Leute, die Lust haben, dort Radio zu machen, können einfach auf diese Redaktionssitzung gehen, auf dieses Treffen von den Leuten und sagen, hey, wir wollen Radio machen und wir haben eine Idee. Zum Beispiel, wir wollen Musik machen, wir wollen einfach eine Reggae-Sendung machen, eine Elektrosendung. Dann kommen viele Leute und sagen, könnt ihr nicht wenigstens noch Info dazu erzählen, damit es nicht einfach nur Musik wird. Aber das kann man auch einfach machen. Oder man kann auch einfach hingehen, wenn man zum Beispiel einfach mal zu Technik erzählen will. Also einfach so eine Nerd-Sendung. Das gibt es auch in ein paar Sendern. Sehr spannend. Also ich bin da sehr begeistert von.
Also viele Sendungen aus dem Chaosradio-Umfeld, also die Darmstädter, C-Radar, die sind halt auch bei dem Radar-Radiosender in Darmstadt untergekommen. Die Nerds on Air in Wien sind bei Radio Orange und so. Also sie sind eigentlich auch überall dort an solchen freien Radios angedockt, genau.
In Hannover gibt es auch bald. Ich habe mit welchen auf den Datenspuren jetzt am Wochenende geredet, die wollen auch einen.
Genau, die Mainzer haben jetzt auch gerade angefangen, CCC Mainz.
Und in Marburg gibt es eine CCC, völlig unabhängige Technik-Sendung. Die setzen sich tatsächlich ins Studio und reden darüber, was sie in der letzten Woche mal wieder an Technik im Radio schrauben mussten. Sehr mühsam zu hören.
Das heißt, da geht es explizit um Radio-Technik.
Genau.
Gibt es davon einen Podcast?
Leider nicht. Das ist aber schade. Ich glaube, das hören nur Nerds, aber es macht Spaß.
Na ja, dann sollte es ja gerade ins Netz.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist eine Elend. Also bei freiesradio.net landet ja auch nicht alles. Man ist ja sozusagen selber gezwungen, erst mal dafür zu sorgen, dass es da überhaupt ankommt.
Da landet viel zu wenig. Also es wird hundertprozentig mehr produziert, als dort landet. Also das ist halt genau unser Problem auch von ZIPFM, dass wir zu wenig Radios haben oder zu wenig Radiobeiträge haben und überhaupt viel zu wenig Leute sich trauen, überhaupt ihre Beiträge zu veröffentlichen. Nicht nur in ihrer kleinen Stadt hörbar zu machen, sondern auch nochmal zu stellen. Ich glaube, das ist einfach das Problem, dass Leute, die Podcast machen, die setzen es ins Netz und es können alle hören. Aber welche, die sich ins Studio setzen, die haben, glaube ich, nicht alle so ein Bewusstsein, wie viele Leute das hören und verdrängen es ganz gerne. Aber dann nochmal den Schritt zu haben, es auch noch ins Netz zu setzen, damit es noch mehr Leute hören können, das schaffen viele einfach nicht.
Wie viele Leute hören denn die freien Radios? Gibt es da irgendwelche Untersuchungen und Zahlen, die du kennst?
Ja, es gibt. Also das kommt von Stadt zu Stadt völlig unterschiedlich drauf an. Zwischen drei und sieben Prozent der Radio-Hörenden hören freie Radios. Also in Nürnberg sind es, glaube ich, fünf, in Freiburg, in Erfurt nur drei.
Was sind das für Untersuchungen?
Es werden immer, das ist ja auch auf allen Mainstream-Sendern zu hören, von den Landesmedienanstalten Untersuchungen gemacht.
Aber ist das nicht nur so, einmal im Jahr rufen wir morgens um sieben die Leute an, holen sie aus dem Bett und fragen, ob sie gerade Radio hören, und wenn ja, was?
Schon, das ist das Problem. Also es wird nicht ganz nur so, sondern es wird auch direkt abgeläuft, schon so, dass Fragen gestellt werden, was sie prinzipiell hören, was mittags gehört, was morgens gehört wird. Es ist natürlich, wie soll man das sagen? Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, dass früher, früher war alles besser. Haben die Leute mehr freie Radios gehört? Also es ist, man könnte sagen, eigentlich ist es mehr out geworden. Also Leute, zum Beispiel in Freiburg ist es einfach so, dass es früher am Küchentisch viel mehr Diskussionen über die letzten Radiobeiträge gab. In der politischen Szene und alternativen Szene allgemein wurde halt gehört und drüber geredet. Inzwischen gibt es kaum Feedback, also viel weniger Feedback, als es noch vor ein paar Jahren war.
Und meinst du, das liegt daran, dass sich so viel ins Internet verlagert?
Nee, zugegebenerweise nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich da so viele andere Kreise tummeln. Also es gibt schon auf jeden Fall natürlich neue Kreise, die podcasten, aber es werden nicht so viele mehr sein, die dann weniger hören. Eigentlich hören die meisten dann gar nichts mehr oder sie steigen auf Deutschlandfunk um, weil Formatradio doch schöner ist zu hören für manche Leute.
Formatradio. Gut, haben wir denn noch irgendwas noch nicht angesprochen, was du noch in dem Kontext ZIPFM oder Freiradios für erwähnenswert hältst?
Ich glaube, ich finde noch zu erwähnenswert, dass alle tatsächlich einfach zu uns kommen können, uns anschreiben können, wie auch immer, und mitmachen können. Also es ist halt nicht nur, wir sind halt tatsächlich nicht die Creme de la Creme der freien Radios, sondern wir sind irgendwelche Leute, die Bock haben, Radio zu machen. Und es ist dann eigentlich, es ist egal, aus welcher Szene man kommt. Klar, wir sind auf jeden Fall irgendwie schon, es geht um, es ist Info- und Politikmagazin, aber es ist auch nicht eingeschränkt. Wir haben, ich bin dabei, ich gebe es zu, deswegen haben wir relativ viel Datenschutz auch drin. Aber alle möglichen Themen, die einfach außerhalb über Musik liegen und nicht rechtslastig sind oder pure Mitte, können bei uns Radio machen.
Da muss ich nochmal nachhaken. Wie ist denn das so mit der Links-Rechts-Positionierung? Also es ist natürlich Freie Radios, ein urlinke Grundansatz. Das ist auch nachvollziehbar. Da ist deutlich mehr der Wunsch nach Meinungsvielfalt und freier Meinungsäußerung zu spüren als jetzt in den rechten Szenen. Die gehen ja eher in die andere Richtung. Inwieweit bemüht ihr euch denn da einen gearteten Ausgleich? Es gibt ja dann mal merkwürdige Vorstellungen von sogenannter Political Correctness, in welche Richtung das auch immer gehen mag. Für den einen darf es nicht zu links, für den anderen darf es nicht zu weit rechts sein. Wie wird denn da der Konsens gefunden? Oder ergibt sich das einfach so?
Es ergibt sich nicht einfach so. Ich glaube, es ergibt sich einfach schon deshalb nicht einfach so, weil es ist eine Gruppe, die sich halt auch viermal im Jahr trifft und irgendwie sich kennt. Und da gibt es halt, ich glaube, schon soziale Auslese, würde ich jetzt mal ganz böse nennen. Also es gibt einfach tatsächlich, hatten wir noch nie Probleme mit Rechten, Meinungen oder irgendwas, oder was uns allgemein zu rechtslastig war.
Also meinst du, es wurde nichts eingereicht, was jetzt in irgendeiner Form in eine Richtung geht, wo alle sagen würden, was ist denn das?
Wir haben aber schon Probleme mit den üblich linken Themen. Also wenn Leute Beiträge zum Irak machen, wir hatten, ne, wir hatten letztens nicht Irak, wir hatten, glaube ich, einen Beitrag zum Kosovo, wo viele mit Bauchschmerzen hatten. Und das wurde dann sehr lange und breit diskutiert, wie wir das machen. Also das ist natürlich ein Problem. Wir sind verschiedene Menschen, wir kommen aus verschiedenen Umfelden. Aber ich würde sagen, wir sind linkslastig. Also wir sind schon noch so typisch freies Radio, linke Politik und Info von unten, oder wie man es auch immer bezeichnen will.
Aber man will jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt, was ich dann auch mal so ein bisschen fragwürdig nicht, aber nicht so spannend finde, sind immer so die Berichte von irgendwelchen hauserbesetzten Häusern, die geräumt werden. Das ist natürlich auch ein wichtiges Thema. Aber die Frage ist, wie kriegt man eine Ausgewogenheit hin? Was will man denn eigentlich bieten als Profil?
Also gerade was Häuserbesetzung angeht, es gab lange Zeit, wir haben immer wieder darüber gestritten, gerade so Häuserkampf-Szenen. Die Leute rennen um die Ecke, jetzt rennen sie gerade um die nächste Ecke und morgen wird das nächste Haus besetzt. Das ist total langweilig. Also für die Stadt, die gerade kämpfen, von mir aus.
Wenn schon dann mit Video, ne?
Wenn schon, stimmt, dann ist es wieder spannend. Aber wir sind nur auf Töne fixiert, was anderes können wir gar nicht bieten und wollen wir auch gar nicht. Wir wollen tatsächlich Infos. Also wenn wir Interviews machen, ist es zum Beispiel für uns total wichtig, kritische Interviewführung zu machen. Also nicht einfach irgendwie, erzählt mal, was ihr gerade irgendwie auf dem Plenum diskutiert habt, sondern auch wirklich zu hinterfragen, sonst ist es für die Hörer und Hörerinnen einfach langweilig. Und ich glaube, dadurch kommt auf jeden Fall von den Leuten, die wirklich so ZIPFM machen, na ja, so eine gewisse Ausgewogenheit schon da. Wenn man kritisch denkt, es geht ja bei uns schon darum, dass die Leute weiterdenken, die der Radio hören und nicht wir denen einfach was erzählen, was sie bitte zu übernehmen haben. Aber wir haben genauso wenig, wie eigentlich der Ansatz von freien Radios ist. Wir haben definitiv nicht den Anspruch, total objektiv zu sein, sondern wir sind ein subjektives Radio.
Klar, das ist ja eigentlich auch fast unmöglich.
Ja, aber es wird behauptet. Also die Mainstream-Radios besuchen es ja nicht. Natürlich ist es unmöglich.
Man muss versuchen, in seiner Subjektivität halbwegs ausgewogen daherzukommen.
Und man muss einfach zugeben.
Genau.
Wir geben es zu.
Wir geben es auch zu. Chaosradio gibt es auch zu. Wir sind auch total subjektiv. Und ja, ich würde sagen, damit haben wir das Thema ZIPFM und Freie Radios ganz gut rübergebracht. Hoffen wir zumindest. Ich bedanke mich bei dir, Wera, für das Kommen, für das Beitragen. Und ich bedanke mich natürlich auch bei euch für das wiederholte Zuhören. Wenn ihr Anmerkungen habt und Kommentare abgeben wollt, ihr wisst schon, gibt's E-Mail-Adresse chaosradio.ccc.de. Und ich will heute auch nochmal die Telefonnummer durchsagen, wo ihr Audio-Kommentare schicken könnt, wenn ihr möchtet. Das ist 018 01 99 33 22 99 55.
Und ich würde gleich auch noch was sagen, nämlich wenn es für uns Anregungen gibt, dann einfach über unsere Seite www.zipfm.net. Dort gibt es dir direkt ein Formular, was einfach Infos, Hinweise, Kommentare uns schicken.
Eine E-Mail-Adresse gibt es nicht?
Es gibt.
Ich verstehe schon.
Wer es rauskriegt, was ich für eine E-Mail-Adresse habe, dann auch an mich.
Dann haben wir es. Dann wünsche ich euch noch viel Spaß am Gerät. Und wir hören uns bald wieder beim nächsten Chaosradio Express.
Auf Wiedersehen!